man I feel like men are in um a
stereotypical mindset where they feel
like they're the big they're the big man
they have to be responsible for paying
for first date and stuff like that so I
feel like that's why they do it
automatically women are traditional men
are more you you're right men are in
more traditional roles than women so
it's like the men are coming to you in a
traditional role they're taking you on a
date they're paying but you're saying I
can't be a traditional woman for him I
can't give him wifely duties when off
the bat before he even knows if he's
gonna get sex from you which is what men
want right he's paying 200 pounds ain't
nothing to a man so let's be honest 200
pounds